hey guys it is Thursday my name is Jeff
I'm Dan and you're watching games but
news here's what's going on today
first up it's almost the weekend but to
help you get the rest of the way there
here's some free games to help pick you
up well maybe it'll perk you up but they
are free games for the next day and a
half Humble Bundle is letting you
collect out lost and the outlast
whistleblower DLC for free the games
previously would have run you just under
30 US dollars but if you want to get
scared shitless buzzer dollars that's
the thing you can do the outlast double
is available on PC Linux and Mac and you
can grab it in steam key form or
drm-free after its announcement on
Monday at Playstations TGS press
conference Square Enix has released a
bunch of new details in a new trailer on
left alive
Komatsu translated a firm itsu article
which says left alive will be a third
personal survival game with big robots
and an apocalyptic setting
what's more the game is set within the
front mission universe main series front
mission games are usually tactical
role-playing games but it's spin-offs
fall into different genres the series is
also famous for giant robots called
bonzers in left alive you'll be able to
fight ones us but also steal them away
from the enemy I really hope that's
monticello as we're just gonna stand
like we assume Germans parental double
uses bees maybe I do I know speech and
you'll play as three protagonists which
you'll switch between as you progress
and the way you progress through levels
is totally up to you there's heaps more
details on this one which you can check
out over on GameSpot left alive got a
fair bit of attention this week thanks
to Metal Gear illustrator
Yoji Shinkawa being attached to the
project this is one to keep an eye on so
keep tuning in right here finally four
more backwards compatible games have
arrived on Xbox one now I'm pretty sure
you're gonna want to play these ones
Taylor
sailor halo combat Evolved Anniversary
halo 3 ODST and halo 4 and now all
playable on Xbox one the full campaigns
and multiplayer are included the latter
of which also includes all the DLC for
free
if you earn any of the games on disk you
can just pop them in and get to play or
install them from your download list if
you've got a digital copy if you want to
see what all the fuss is about
seriously ODST is worth it for fire
fight alone you can grab each of the
games separately on the Xbox digital
marketplace you can also grab the Master
Chief collection for a fully remastered
version of Halo 2 along with the rest
now let's type it out sure yep what are
you going to say
we'll say the top five you're cleaning
that up hey guys it's Thursday
let's not okay here's the thing here no
idea that's what easy here's the thing
hey guys imagine all right let's not
really